in this video I'm going to teach you how
to create a website just like other
professionals do it now you will find
yourself tempted to memorize the code
but in reality most programmers don't
memorize the code at all they usually
follow documentation and anytime they
want to remember something they just
copy it from the other files so don't
feel tempted to memorize everything to
get started you want to go ahead and
open your web browser because we're
going to install the required software
but before we do so I want to go ahead
and talk to you about HTML which is the
first language you're gonna have to
learn in order to create a website so
hTML is not a programming language
instead it's a markup language so
basically a markup language is like the
outside template of your website so to
give you a demonstration on how this
will work let's visit a very simple
website like like for instance this
website what saw out if I were to click
on I want to open a source code so yep
you're gonna right click on the web page
and click on View page source
all right there we go this is more
legible so if we scroll down everything
it's from here down until about here is
HTML then we have HTML right here
downwards so this may look a little
tempting but don't worry this is a very
large website very large scale it has a
lot of JavaScript a lot of indentation
so there's no need to worry about doing
this and has some styling in the middle
so it's not like pure HTML so no need to
compare but every web site is so
basically the every web site has to be
outputting in HTML because the browser
can only read HTML now for this course
you will need a browser and a text
editor so for a browser I have Google
Chrome but you can choose your own so
for our text editor we will be using
visual studio code so you can go
together from code visual studio
now you want to go ahead and download
this please just do the code and then so
while you're setting I have it installed
already but while you're setting it up
it'll ask you an option to add it to
like the file context menu like with LC
like open with Co which is generally
this so if I were to open my file
explorer like here for instance I can
just click on open a code and I'll be
able to open it with Visual Studio
coding on your on your desktop or
anywhere you want to create a file I
mean this is where we're gonna store our
website a basically a new folder this
and you want to call this folder web
development course so inside of that
folder now today we're gonna be creating
three websites in which two websites are
just sand boxes so they're not gonna
look very pretty
the first website is gonna be called
it's going to be called HTML sandbox now
you can do the manual way of creating
folder but if you want you can follow
along and download get bash from I'll
show you where you can get it from just
search on google get bash this the
second link and it's download the
Windows version and then you can get get
bash and then so these are basically
Unix commands available on Windows so
this will allow you to do is use like
sort of like Linux commands on a Windows
system so I'm gonna go ahead and make
the font size bigger so you can read it
alright so now you want to go in and you
want to create a new file inside of this
folder so for the UNIX command for
creating a new file is touch and then
the name of the file which is index out
HTML which one Korea but we do not want
to create inside this folder we will
create a new folder which is a directory
in which you will say make door so
basically make directory what do you
want to call your folder well I want to
call it
HTML underscore sandbox and you'll see
it's created here now we want to get
inside our folders you can create our
next files now we want to go ahead and
see
so basically go into that folder in
which what we call but well I should say
you don't remember what you call this
folder and you don't have this open so
you can use a command called LS it'll
tell you what folders you have so you
can see here I have HTML sandbox so now
I'm going to basically do CD into HTML
underscore sandbox
now I'm inside of HTML sandbox and you
can clearly verify for right here so
inside of here I want to talk about in
that's how HTML so index.html is the
entry point for a website home page so
whenever you upload the website to a
server to a service whatever it's gonna
look for index.html to load your web
page so basically your home page now you
do not want to call it home dot HTML the
server is not going to know which file
to open you're just going to show a
directory list of files and then let the
user decide but we do not want to let
the user decide on what file to open in
which we will specify index.html now you
can go ahead now we can do an LS here
and see we have index.html and if I were
to open this you will see index our HTML
now at this point you can go ahead and
right-click inside the folder and click
on open with code but if you follow the
other method of just using windows
itself it's simple just new new folder
and just follow along now for a dog dog
HTML extension now you may not have this
available at your first just want to go
down to view and write and check file
name extensions which will allow you
this now you can either right click in
here and fold and click on open with
code but I'm not gonna do that
if you have git bash and you and when
you were installing visuals to your
clothing and clicked on add visual
studio to pass then you should be able
to do code and then dart for inside this
folder and they'll open visual studio
code on its own now you'll see that
visual studio code that it displays
index.html now do not be worried by just
looking at the format this text editor
is mate might be overwhelming for some
of you but don't worry it's
simple now one extension busy extension
so let me talk with sentience for a
while so extensions are like add-ins for
a text letter which make them more and
more powerful so you can see here have a
couple of extensions but one extension
we will need it's called live server
right here so you want to go ahead and
click install and install and
automatically but if so basically I will
show you them what the live server does
so you have two options of viewing that
so go ahead and type hello world here to
stimulate that and now go ahead and go
back to your files and now you have two
options you can either open this file
manually double clicking now the
downside to opening like that is almost
split screen for a second the downside
for opening that way is let's just a
triad whole world and I save here so if
I do say ctrl s for save I had to come
back here and reload which can be tiring
as soon as you get into more so what
that so what live server does for us is
it allows us to just right click and
click on open with live server so inside
a live server you can see it has went
ahead and opened it for us now if I were
to split screen these now it will give
me some alerts to let me know about so
now I can just gonna do how I can like
remove the house and then do control s
and visual pseudocode and it should
automatically so it won't automatically
reload right now until we get into
talking about the structure of a web
page then I'll show you reloading but
basically if I click ctrl s inside a
code editor it should automatically
reload the browser so now if you want to
increase the font size which is inside
of file preferences and settings and
you're gonna control the font size so
I'm going in for this purpose of the
video I'm your 20 all right so now this
should be pretty big all right now let's
going to talk about the structure of a
web page so each web page has a
structure and now we're creating HTML
file but there's different types of HTML
and now we're learning html5 which is
the latest everyone use is everyone's
using it basically so every webpage is
displayed in that and Google and all
browsers are supported now here's one
thing if you if you haven't just defined
like Chrome as your default browser and
it opens live server and edge just going
to copy the URL close out of it open
Chrome paste it in just give it a second
and ocean this should be fine now we
want to declare this document as an
html5 document so there's this weird
syntax you have to learn its angle
bracket open explanation point doctype
and HTML now once again just in case if
you is doctype and then HTML now you do
not have to do capitalize as i sometimes
become lazy and just do like that
totally dependent on you but the main
point is you're getting the main point
of doctype and an HTML so basically this
is declaration of the defines that this
is an html5 document so no one can come
now and say there's a HTML for HTML 3
which ever like it doesn't matter now we
want to create the roots of this web
page so our roots live inside an element
called HTML so now all elements come in
pairs so if I were to do HTML so I start
angle bracket HTML sound watch what
happens as soon as I break my right
angle bracket automatically the ESCOs
tries to be helpful and gives us the
second pair so now all elements come in
pairs so it makes sense why I did that
now if you press ENTER between it
creates this space which is totally fine
the space is totally fine in which
inside we're gonna call something called
nesting elements so we're gonna nest
another element inside of this so now we
want to where would we define the web
page title because if we go here you can
see visual studio code as its own title
but here we have like 127.0.0.1 port
number 550 500 index our HTML this is
not very user friendly so inside if you
here we want to go to head element so
now the same thing press enter in
between elements which will give you the
space inside a head elements we can
define the meta information the titles
style sheets everything so mostly
anything that isn't displayed on the
webpage is usually going to be in here
and it's like external so we can go in
and create a title element and now let's
call this title hello world and if I
save not reload here hello world now I
can change this to anything and call it
HTML and now if I save here it
automatically reloads here because it
has the necessary tasks to reload but
now I'm we're just gonna stick to the
title HTML sandbox because this is only
has our sandbox where we play with HTML
code we creating you we like create
elements all that fun stuff don't worry
it's not gonna be hard this is a
challenge so now inside of here we don't
create a body so now body is where the
elements are visible to the user so if I
do body now inside of your you can do
this is everything you type in here
gibberish even is displayed to the user
all right but this is very small but I'm
gonna teach you tags that will make a
very bigger now let me save this once
again hTML is on the more go so right
now our webpages are not going to look
as beautiful until we get to something
called CSS which is cascading style
sheets now do not worry about CSS right
now as I will go over that in this video
don't worry but you'll eventually get to
that so I want to go ahead and teach you
something on so mouse display element on
a web page so gonna do h1 once again
visual studio code becomes helpful so
let me explain to you what's going on so
we're in jizan type go ahead and type
hello world and then you have like you
have hello world displayed on your
browser yeh so just have created your
first web page now let me tell you what
is basically happening here so here's
what you're saying
hey browser this is html5 document so
this tag you're telling the browser this
is html5 and then now we're calling for
browser again disturbing the browser
again and be like hey browser here's the
root of our webpage and then hey browser
take our meta information and our title
a browser
I want this title to be the title of my
webpage now hey browser close the header
because I finished my meta and then now
we're hey browsers start to open
workspace we're gonna start and then
each one so this is a one heading so
this is a largest heading available in
HTML so you're basically saying the
brother hey browser
give me a heading one by declaring this
so anything inside is h1 is gonna look
very similar until you get into CSS but
this is one heading this is one element
you just have successfully created an
HTML element that displays on a web page
so now this isn't very helpful to us
just learning h1 so let's just say I
want to comment this so comments are
useful to let like if I other developer
was to come over and wants to see how
much work you put into your webpage they
can come over and then see that oh so
this means this that means that
basically so how will we put this in
like human form like how will we tell
another human that this is an h1 element
that says our world without it them
actually open the code so that's where
comments come in so we go laughing go
bracket exclamation point double hyphens
and then inside it there you can type
anything so videos to your code has
become inside you that and then so
basically that's the beginning of that
comment and then you can close a comment
just like that and then inside of this
you can put a comment so we're gonna say
hello world
okay now comments are not displayed to
the user so everything in the comment is
going to be displayed here not hear
anything on comments is only displayed
to the developer that's working inside
the code editor so while this is not you
fall at the moment where doesn't start
so now we want the clip now to declare a
comment inside Visual Studio code the
fastest way is to control and then you
might press ctrl on your keyboard and
then forward slash and increase the
automatic comment so let's talk about
all of our headings so I'm gonna create
a comment of headings so now we couldn't
merrily type out h1 which takes a lot of
time but I want to show you visuals to
your code shortcut just type h1 and then
tab it will create this h1 element for
us so inside of this h1 I want to go so
we're creating like a cheat sheet
sandbox sort of thing so it's like easy
for you to study with so I won't put
some text in here which is gonna help
you understand h1 so this is a heading
with an h1 time so you can put almost
anything in the sound of h1 so any word
add anything you basically want but for
the purpose of this video I'm just gonna
put heading with h1 tags so like we know
that's the h1 like you do not want to
mess this up so now we're using our
short cover and create another element
which is the h2 which is going to be
smaller than our each one but not
significantly so heading with h2 time
and it's definitely it is smaller now
you will see that by default some of
these have like space in between of them
now we can get rid of that space using
CSS but don't worry we'll get to that as
well the next element you want to create
is a h3 so this is a heading with an h3
tag now you can go on out going to now
there's six types of heading so you can
go ahead and move on and create your own
element until it's eight six so going to
explore alright so now we have created
six different headings now you can see
eight six it's pretty tiny I'm pretty
sure no one's to read that on a web page
so for that that's what CSS exists so
you know how to deal with this mini
eight six which in reality I haven't
used a six and a long time since doing
web development
so now we've I've showed you headings
but it doesn't look very pretty like
headings
they're like bolded so you don't want
your text like that so that's why
paragraphs exist so put another comment
and I'm gonna say paragraph so now
there's only one time to remember about
paragraph so yeh we don't have to
remember too much so you want to pee cow
now inside these P tags we want to go
ahead and type any paragraph one so
inside this is a paragraph but that
isn't very helpful at all
now that is helpful indeed but it isn't
very helpful to us to like display like
a paragraph so now there's a now let's
just say we're prototyping a website
like testing a website to see how it
will look and play around we might not
have content so for that reason Visual
Studio has a very handy tag which is
Laura and then now how many words you
want so we can see even 3,000 words 3
million whatever but I want 30 words
alarm so you do Lauren 30 tab and just
develop 30 words and lorem ipsum which
is dummy text basically so now this is
how a paragraph look like now Google
Chrome might prompt you to translate the
page just because lorem is not pure
English but yeah you don't have to worry
about that now let's talk about links so
now you go on a web page on visuals to a
web page again now we just find a link
to click on well let's look on our
privacy there's privacy statement so now
it basically takes you to an external
page now we can do accomplish the same
thing with our website so you want to go
and put a comment for links and then
here the links have it so now they're
there used a a tag with H ref is where
you're pointing to so why are you
pointing to which is href and then
closing time so now inside of a crowd
that's where you put where you want to
go you can so if I were to go
and like let's just say you were extra
now this was your website and you told
someone to go to Google calm
number one they just have left your
website so you just lost a visitor
apparently just because you made them
click on that link so now there's a
really easy way to make this open in a
new tab in which is so now elements have
attributes so attribute is define very
different things so we have an attribute
which is called target now if I type in
target visual studio code we'll add an
equal sign and then the quotation
basically this href is also attribute
for this link so inside of here
just type in underscore blank now
there's would be something different if
I click on clicked me we're in a new tab
so we still have that visitor that came
to our website so let's review what we
have learned so the first thing that I
taught you guys was that every file that
that is a HTML file must have the
extension dot HTML now sorry if you
can't see this but it's really small the
dot HTML is right here it is literally
everywhere reminding you that you need
dot HTML now the first time that we
learned when creating a web site was the
doctype HTML now this declares his file
as an html5 document and not a XHTML
file document so we are writing HTML
file 5 and not any other time and then
first begin the roots of the document
like basically the beginning and the end
point of the document is HTML the tags
the HTML now we learned also that HTML
tags come in pairs like always and then
the head tag same thing in pairs is Z
like where the titles held a meta tag
everything now here's one topic I
haven't talked about and that is nesting
elements so here you will see that the
title tag is actually nested inside the
head tag and so is all this nested
inside the this stuff is nested inside
of the body to the body is nested inside
the HTML tag
head tag is also nested inside HTML and
everything is basically one hierarchy
now here's one thing I haven't talked
about and that is the indentation so you
want to keep your file neat and clean so
it is easy to read now if I were to go
ahead and now indentation not important
for the browser so you can literally do
is basic rewrite just the whole entire
thing that we have written so far in a
very ugly format so just watch how ugly
it could get and you will soon to find
out that it is impossible to nearly read
and then we had to get out the head
they're gonna get into the body tag and
then inside of here we have to put an h1
that says hello world so now this might
be one line so yeah but just by looking
at this if I had more of this so like if
I put let's just say all this in there
but let's just I was four more elements
you can clearly see that it is becoming
hard to read and we won't know where
elements end we got soon as we get into
the harder elements it will become
harder to read so that's why indenting
documents is better so if I was to go
ahead and indent this a little bit maybe
not the best intention but a lot better
they're a lot more suitable to me so
number one you do not want to do this
how to doc types and one document to
HTML and two bodies and two heads that
will confuse it but yeah you can you can
clearly take away that indentation makes
the document easier to read and so does
nesting so nest so every time you Nessa
element inside an element just have it
over it will be so much easier so now
let's move on to something with
organization so we want to organize our
like let's just say one McCrystal it's
now you can create a list but what we
have learned just by using paragraphs so
we can say list item
this item so you can sort of create a
list I mean not the best list of the
world but hey it's a list alright so
instead we're going to learn something
proper so let's include our comment for
lists now we have two types of listen
hmm
so if we have two types so now you have
unordered list and order the list so now
on the order list have a tag of UL while
order lists have a tag of oh well so now
inside of each list you still use the
same tag so you nest list items inside
of a list container basically so you're
basically clearing a container so let's
start with an unordered list so you well
now inside of here we're nesting so
we're gonna be nesting upon list item so
let me go ahead and like save so we can
get rid of this but anyway let's move
let's type in Li so this is list I saw a
lie stands for list item so it's gonna
comment that up your li stands for list
item so inside of each list item you can
inside of every alike of one list item
or many as you want but I would
understand why would you want to do that
so inside this Li let's do list item one
and you will see they have some pre
format tation like we get this bullet
point for free and basically we almost
did nothing except by ul and Li now here
let me teach you one interesting thing
if I were to create an li without it it
creates it but it doesn't have that nice
indentation of going on to the right
like it will just stay like that so you
can do allies basically which will
create a bullet point but it's better to
do inside a ul so it looks more
indicated but once again just CSS this
won't be wrong
so let's just create larger list
now you can get the idea of what I'm
talking about now this is a nautilus how
about odorless well we already mentioned
that order list or oh well tax so let's
do oh well inside if you're going to the
same allies so we'll do list item one
list item two now guess what an order
list will look like I haven't told you
what order list looks like so I want you
to pause the video and think about it
how would an order list look like
alright so order list spoiler alert
has numbers now for you guys to not look
all the way this down so now you don't
have to copy this time and quickly do
some funky magic
there so you guys do not have to you do
not have to copy this don't worry but I
just did this so you don't have to keep
on looking on the bottom so if you have
order list so bees have numbers
basically now basically the purpose of a
list is to organize your data and while
this is pretty good organized let's talk
about text formats text formatting like
bold in our words italics underline
highlighting subscript superscript like
if you're like creating a Matthew close
you might want to do exponents or
subscripts whatever so I'm Creole create
a common for text formatting now some of
the most popular tabs for text
formatting will be if you want to bold
your text you will want to use the
strong ties and then if you wanted to
italic your text you would use the e/m
tags if you wanted to underline your
text you would you will use au tags if
you wanted to highlight your text or
highlight you would use the mark tags
and then if you wanted to add a
subscript so that will be a small number
on the bottom which you'll see in a
second you will see subtext and then if
you want it to superscript which is like
an exponent you will do the soup tags
now let's going to test some of these
tags out so we're going now these can be
nested inside of a paragraph and these
are some inline elements which I'm going
to mention right now
so basically inline elements are
elements that stay on the same line so
for instance a tags are also in line but
since its parent was a block level
element a block level element basically
means it's gonna be honest um on line
then this moved on the next
so let me show you how that will look
like so if I were to go in and create a
paragraph inside this paragraph we're
gonna type this board is going to be and
then inside of here
let's go in create a strong tax for
bolding this text bold so this is an
inline element it did not move to its
own line like it did not do this so it
did not move to his own line has said it
stayed on the same line and it took the
same amount of width as it needed it's
like this thing did not take up like a
whole entire space so look if I were to
continue typing after the strong to this
it still it took up the space and needed
that's a inline element well block line
element just takes up a whole new line
so that is bold now it's going to look
at italics this is a table italicized
then let's gonna look at sorry this now
we're gonna look at underlined so
underlined it which is gonna be the you
tax really easy to remember now it's
gonna look at a tag I haven't talked
about sorry which is a small tag
so basically dislike smalls your text up
we will see in a second but we use the
small ties so really easy I remember so
first that we'll just use small small
small now you can use actually use all
these extra tags on your own but if so I
could do strong this text is bold you
could do that you could do but then
these will have like their own type of
styling like they won't be a paragraph
tag like you can do this to this Texas
italics and then you could also do this
text is underlined but many times you
won't want to do it with an element and
now you can see these are inline
elements so they don't go on their own
line automatically so they just continue
after one another even though they're on
separate lines now let's talk about
spacing I could press 100 inners and
then even have a small tag down here and
to save this and it still comes here but
what happened to all these spaces I have
like I worked so hard to create these
well apparently whitespace does not
matter to the browser instead for that
reason we have something called line
breaks now you will see I did not put a
I did not put an ending time so I did
not do this now that is in correct
format but this is a self closing time
so busy self-closing tags close
themselves like you won't need anything
else so if I were to go ahead and create
this break tag this is a line break you
won't see anything happen but if I was
to go ahead and do like a paragraph with
lorem 20 and then like for like couple
line breaks under that as well now you
can do them on the same line and then we
do lorem 10 again we have all this extra
space due to this break so I could even
to prove it to you do this and we still
have extra space build our line break so
there are auto closing tags so we can
gonna talk about line breaks right now
beforehand and say they're self closing
and create and use the BR tag all right
now let's going to move back so let's go
back to the small tags I was talking
about so let's go back up here to our
disk and box now let's not talk about
the highlighting example so this word is
going to the
we do mark tag highlight it and then
voila just Texas highlighting now it's
gonna do a subscript so this word is
going to be a sub so just subscript and
then this is a basically a subscript let
me zoom in more this is a subscript
basically but what though that so
subscript is basically it goes below the
word sorter and then we have another
paragraph time this is gonna be a
superscript basically like an exponent
sooo first correct exactly so this is
raised basically alright now we have
talked about most of the text formatting
I want to talk about grouping your
elements but while we were talking on
line breaks what if you want a straight
line like your separate your content
with well that's why what's like a
charge exists so these are visiting
lines to separate your content and they
use the HR tab these are also self
closing so so clothing so I can go in
and put an HR between let's just sit
here and if we get a pretty
organizational line here now I'll move
this so now let's go back and see where
we could actually use the line HR so we
can do a chart here
HR here to separate our content width so
we know what we're talking about this is
all this this is all text formatting
now if we go back our content looks a
lot more organized like it's a lot
easier to read instead of the other
gibberish now here I kind of went on my
own so I might want to do HR now so this
is great right now at the moment so
let's move on to grouping our elements
so you want to group your elements a
little like let's just say you had a
blog article which we're about to write
so there's an element for this is called
a div so a div is basically and does
nothing except it groups your elements
so we can do div and then we can go
ahead and group our elements so we'll go
ahead and add a h1 say this is some text
now we're running an article later but
we can do like P then lorem xx and then
you go see here this text will always be
inside this div so it's a lot easier to
see what's going on now how can we like
get our groups our name so think back to
elementary school when your teacher
divided you guys into groups now inside
of these groups you guys had to decide a
name now basically that's what we're
gonna do be doing we're gonna add an
attribute to our div so an attribute to
our discipline now these so attributes
to a div that give it a name or called
classes and ID's now you may be thinking
what do these do well they actually they
are therefore to identify a group of
elements for a single purpose so
basically for like multiple purposes or
so you might we will catch on these
classes and ID's in CSS more and
JavaScript and by the way javascript is
a programming language used with HTML so
let's gonna create let's just create a
h1 again we'll just call it hello and
then a pair
when Lauren like lorem 20 what's
happening there and then let's create
another paragraph to simulate this so
Brenda have to paragraph let's add an HR
to divide our content there so you can
see we're like using what we're learning
to help us learn more stuff now let's go
add your view to this div so I'm gonna
start with a class now a class is
basically a name so let's just give this
element like this whole entire group a
name so we just called it the hello
alright so now we can catch on this
later with the hello but let's just
create another one of this to show to
simulate ID and an ID it's basically so
basically the difference between ID and
a div is that a div and sorry an ID in
the class is that a class is you can be
most used multiple time so let's just
say we were saying that this is a
article while she's saying no let's call
this a hello live right just like we did
before but let's just call now we can ID
v to be more specific like this is all
about your you like you don't have to
use ID that don't even just rely on
classes all the time but we can call
this like hello - this is a second hello
but Hello is more my class is more like
general so like you can use this class
any else where you want when ID is
unique to itself stuff like a driver's
license is unique to you like you can
give it to your son and tell them to
drive now using what we have learned we
can actually create a blog article so we
can put an HR and then call it a blog
article now it won't be the prettiest
blog article but hey it'll be an article
so let's start with a div and let me
teach you a quick shortcut if after it
if I put a dot so that's how you
identify classes you're gonna after that
dot you can actually create the class
name so we can call it article tab and
then I press ENTER here to get the
spacing voila so our class
our class is article now so it already
gave that identification now inside of
here let's put in a ch3 with some title
and then let's do a small tag and we'll
now let's gonna say it is post and
usually use small tagging the blog for
who was opposed to by so let's call it
let's say it's post by nano and if I
were to scroll down here we have this
extra space in between bubbling get rid
of that with CSS which we're not gonna
get into right now and then we create a
paragraph tag for the article content
and dual-arm 20y does not want to work
there we have just created an article
but lushes saying we want to link this
to an external page so we use the a now
whenever you're testing like you're
building a website prototyping basically
you can use a hash sign instead of an
actual link so it will still work just
like a normal link except it just won't
go anywhere except we'll just take it to
talk to page apparently yeah but it just
doesn't go anywhere so you can have a
link without it going anywhere so this
is our mini blog article HR again and we
have a blog article now you see how this
line is sort of close to this well with
CSS you could fix that but with HTML
just put a blame break looks even now
now we talked about lists which are
great ways to organize your content but
let's talk about tables now tables are a
great way to organize your content but
the tags for the table are pretty hard
to remember and then we're also running
out of time so let me going to create a
table tag now this just identifies the
table and then now we want a table head
that is where the content will be bolded
and that'll be like the top content of
your table so let's do a tea head
exactly you're behind remember this now
let's create a table role so basically a
row is this way call them this way but
you don't create columns and you do
create columns but you can create them
right now so to create a table head
column you do th and then let's go to
fictional table for like a customer list
so ID and for like they're like IDs like
one two three four let's have another
table head what column for our name and
then for their phone number this is the
end of your table head now also buddy
now if I were to save this these columns
are bolded that's the purpose of having
th and T table head now how about a
table body well we can do the same and
then here's one thing I messed up I'm
sorry you want to create a table also
and copy this create a table row and
then put it now that you look a lot
better and then you're going to fix the
indentation by using shift tab to go
back now inside this table body when
create a table row every time you're
creating new row remember table row
table book and then in stuff now we're
going to change up a bit so we're going
to create a regular table content so
we're gonna do TD tag inside the CD
tagging up some anything so we put one
here for instance and then next TD tag I
put Smith and then the next TD tag I put
the number if I say hey you can see it
displays here now this is very very ugly
but this can be easily fixed with CSS so
don't worry so let's create another
table row and then in here I'll another
TD they'll be one and then I'll have
another TD which will be Smith and
another TD which will be another weird
phone number so I'll just come up with a
weird one
and then yeah sorry this should be Tom
this should've been - okay now let's
gonna now let me teach you a little a
visual studio code shortcut so if you're
using those students code you can go
ahead and highlight this TR edit press
ctrl shift and then down now this will
create another table row for you go to
three and then this can be used on any
line of code and then we'll do David at
this and then we'll just do 99 now this
looks pretty ugly but don't worry CSS
can easily fix that now let's move on to
something that I think many people
should be excited about and that is
buttons now apparently sorry but there's
only one type of button as you can
create and I'll be with a button tag and
then we'll call this whoops a button is
clicked and I was gonna create our HR
here I've discussed earlier about now
just like everything else the buttons
can take attributes too so we'll do
another button and then let's take an
attribute of disabled and it'll say this
abled as our name now you can see I
cannot no longer click on that now let's
create another button and we can do it
we can give it up attribute or reset
and then Risa alright let's move on to
the next type of stuff now I'm gonna
start speeding up a bit because I think
you guys got the drill of HTML and then
if you want to look into this more on
future I want to review or something
there's a really helpful website so let
me just show you guys you can go ahead
and visit w3 schools calm and then they
have an HTML reference list so
everything I have talked about can
probably be found in here if not then I
mean I probably talked something wrong
but most likely it should be found in
here if you want to review it can be
easily found in here so let's just move
on to forms and then we'll go ahead and
like then we'll have to start we'll just
move on so let me find my notes all
right so forth so for form a form has
starts with the form tag so when you
think both as soon as I press tab on
visuals through your code it gives me
this action attribute now by default
it's not like so if you have created a
website with Webley Wix you would have
never had to dealt with this so like you
go to this create a form and then it'll
be submit when ever come someone comes
you can submit it and you won't have to
give me care about it apparently but now
in HTML is all about your own database
so like so right now you can be cannot
submit this form anywhere but I'll show
you really cool way you could submit
this form but it won't submit it will
instead will just create like our own
search box sort of thing for Google
search box so you'll see later in the
tutorial so and here usually people will
pull like form dot PHP or something but
since we have none of that we can go and
get rid of that we won't have even care
about that so inside of these form tasks
now inside of a form you might you might
see the label book let's go and create
our a chart here before doing that so
inside we can gonna put a label
now our label how the automatic
attribute as well this is a four
attribute now you now the four attribute
is basically the name of us so I want to
create feel for first name but if I save
nothing shows because the 4rq boot is
not displayed to the user instead
between these tags is whatever displayed
to the user so instead of label first
name now you do not need this if you do
not want it and then it'll still look
the same but hey Japan now it's going to
create our input now you will see an
attribute is known as text a type which
is text so now there's different types
of types in HTML let me show you so so
we just got a form here's our input now
you're going to input unless anything
almost anything so now you will see this
is on the same line but how do we learn
to like break your lines or some sort
well we learned with the break the BR
tag which is line break now this is
still touching which I do not like
another line break this still looks ugly
but I see ie 34 into CSS so it's no big
deal why so now someone now there's more
types so one of the types of input there
is an email type which is amazing now
let me talk about the shortcut I just
did so I did input and then colon and
then you have all these types seriously
you're gonna play all all around but now
I can type in the type on one so let's
do email type and then press tab it
gives these two extra so we learned
about one attribute which is the ID
attribute and then the second attribute
is the name attribute so basically
you're just giving this field a name
like you just gave yourself a name when
you were born now you're giving this
thing a name which you're not even
worried about and then it creates an
email field but let's gonna create a
label so we know what we're talking
about
so email now this looks ugly break and
then you need another break here and
then we need another break here to
situate that issue there we go now by
default this comes with some validation
so I cannot I can just do Jo at
gmail.com this will let me through but
if I were to do like Jo
if I press ENTER yeah we're going to
need some advice so don't worry let me
make sure that I'm not screwing up all
right yeah we're gonna get some
abundancy now lets going to talk about
the summit but I'm like because we need
one right now apparently so it's an
input type so we do input : summit for
this is shortcut now by what these
shortcuts are because we were using
Emmet which is pre-installed and visuals
to go so no needed work now there's
value attributes a new one so if I were
to just save we have a blink button but
the value is what's displayed to the
user so we'll say some it there I was
going to add another line break to make
it look good
so now if I were to just say Jo and
click Submit it gives me this amazing
alerts like pre color everything so well
you know you might want to use an email
attribute the next time you do it now
there's one type of attribute I think
you're gonna love and that is you just
have to put this here and this is the
required attribute so if I were to
submit this form without it which
apparently did apparently but let's just
say I put like a a a and then click
Submit apparently I didn't work oh wait
we put this required on the submit
button so obviously you click on the
submit button why did I even do that so
now if I were to sum it please fill this
field out this is a required field
now if I were just say a it still it's
like there's
odd sign you can't so I can do act and
then it's still bugging me saying that's
not completely I can do Gmail calm and
it'll probably let me submit yep
probably submit and it did but
apparently did not go anywhere because
we have nothing to find so now you could
now we can sit here all day defining
attributes and all but if same website
again now in here they have they talked
about forms so if I were just go ahead
and show you so this is under the HTML
tab and then we went to HTML forms or
input attributes here that so we just go
into forms we have like hundreds of
difference so I will talk about not any
more of these forms but you can get them
all from here like copy and paste Lorne
it's pretty simple stuff and then you
have improved attributes which I talked
about one right now and that would so
you have a disabled attribute your size
max links and then you have like
autocomplete your min max disabled
amazing so quick we just talked about it
required and let me talk about one more
attribute which is the placeholder so
let's just say you wanted your customer
to enter this data in some sort of
format so we use placeholder and we'll
say enter first name and then we'll like
have like xxx to show it and then like
they can enter so that was amazing
but before so before this even existed
in HTML you had to do this through the
JavaScript and then now there is one
type of attribute which is a value
attribute and we'll say enter first name
but you will find this immediately this
is basically playing tax this is not
anything so when you click on it you'll
still have it
that's why placeholder is a valuable
resource because it works it just works
so let's quickly do a select list so I'm
not leaving you hanging anywhere so a
form select list I will quickly speed
through this so we have a select
and then you have all these extra
attributes which once again they're now
required by default we do option and
then let me teach you omit abbreviation
shortcut so if I were to do option and
then I want to create three options I
just do the asterisk sign and then three
if I took that we got three options but
they do nothing apparently so I just
have to do option one option two and
then option three
and then here's our select list but
let's just say but sometimes on websites
you're not allowed to click on the first
one and then there's like a weird new
type so we can actually have an option
and then we can have an attribute of
disabled and then we'll say select like
we're gonna do like - - select to make
it look professional but you will soon
to realize it's only visible here not
anywhere else so being added another
attribute which is a selected attribute
save and then this is pre-selected so
this option will be pre-selected and
then your user cannot click on this they
have to choose one of this one of these
all right now this does look weird since
the submit button this is after the
submit so I can just copy the submit
button and then move it down here
alright so now let's talk about text
areas which or four messages basically
still be kind of label for message and
it's a message and then yeah we're gonna
you line breaks apparently because CSS
is not available at the moment so if I
were to do in line break there so inside
of here let's do a text area now text
areas are not self closing and I can get
rid of all these attributes you want
able to care about them and then you
have to put nothing but for a line break
and then here
this is extendable and you said this is
a message it has this weird font which
can also be fixed with CSS so no big
issue right now we're going to CSS later
now let's go ahead and yeah there's a
lot of solace so there's a lot of what's
called input types that you don't have
to worry about now let's talk about
images so we do if we talk about so we
can create an image tag with IMG tap now
in now this is a new attribute just like
our href attribute this is a source
attribute so inside of here we put our
image so we can just go to Google and
say image literally with our images and
just find a good image so I like let's
just say we like that image I just click
on a copy image or address and paste it
in here and if I say we will hopefully
see it but this number one this image is
way too big number two let's talk about
this attribute the alternate text
attribute so if I were to say image of
night sky let's just say you know if it
was probably not and if I save you will
see nothing yet
but let's just say there was an issue
loading the image let's just say I had a
mistake and I made a stupid mistake well
we will have this text and stuff so you
just still get the message out to your
user in some way all right now let's go
ahead and so let me go in same images
and it's gonna do a break time to
actually space it out all right so now
we're going to do that our nap ball
creating a nav bar no I think you're
gonna be pretty excited about learning
by the nav bar
so basically nav bar has an HTML tag of
math if I do mouse inside of here it's
an unordered list now in now won't
create links so we use the a tag inside
of a lie
and then in here we don't specify where
we want to go
so index.html is gonna be our home so
now
here is where you put it home so we just
click on home we're back to our home
page now let's create a new page now to
create a new page of an HTML document
you go here a new file inside the same
directory the same folder about dart
HTML now let me teach you a vs code
shortcut is or M a shortcut in other
words if you do shift 1 or exclamation
point basically now you will see M an
abbreviation just click on new tab and
you get a predefined template ready to
go so I'm going to say this my about
page and I'm ready to rock and roll
I'd say about something just say about
pain now let's head back to index.html
and let's create another navbar item and
we called about our HTML and then I do
about given about now if I click on
about what about that yay so we have
just created our about page so this is
really cool now I want to go ahead and
get to talk about basically like section
structuring and everything so if I was
to go back to this website and I want to
show you guys I'm just if I go back to
the home page and I do like learn there
will be an image here or it used to be
there I hope still there
it's probably yeah
so exactly so it gives you this thing
gives you a lot of information like you
don't even need my hope you could just
have read this but you know it's great
to watch a video and learn you can do it
anywhere almost someone's a formatting
where would I be exactly it's somewhere
definitely but let's just look it up on
Google so we'll do a HTML page structure
probably somewhere
something like this if I can
there there we go this is what I'm
looking for so if I were to just open
this in a new tab so you can just do
open image a new tab so I can zoom in
now so you'll see this is how you like
basically create a web page you have
your header on top nav and then section
article footer aside so now I do not use
the article tag I use so basically I
create this whole area as a section this
is my horse right now Bart is my aside
and it's my footer so to give you an
idea what I mean
I mean none of this will be structured
this way until you CSS so I can go in
and structure it header now inside this
header I like having my navbar so I just
do now have now inside of my navbar
so you can see they use the exact same
time now the inside navbar we can create
our nav bar just as I've taught you guys
and we'll do index.html and then this
will be our home page and then let's do
about dot HTML that will be my about
page now if I were to look back here in
the sandbox and let's go into about me
this might include on home and we're
here yay and then outside of my nav and
outside of my header now let's have a
title quickly so inside the header let's
put an h1 for inside a header obviously
I'm saying my about page and then if I
was to go to about it is there now it's
outside my header loss critter section
inside this section we might want a
paragraph that says this is an about a
section and then we have another
paragraph for like lorem 20 30 something
like that and then outside the section
let's put it aside so this will be like
your sidebar but it won't look like a
sidebar so if you occur in like a blog
or something you Marvin like have links
to external
categories are talking about something
so you might want to Li and then you'll
see like item one as you're a sidebar or
like it would be like item two there so
this like your snap aside to even though
it doesn't look like it now footer
there's something really cool about the
footer now I want you to know so I can
do copyright so this inside a paragraph
tag now if you do now we one create that
see with the circles of the copyright
symbol you can do ampere stamp copy
semicolon and then we do 2019 and we get
that simple so you know a little trick
and then we can do all rights reserved
now on maybe the best webpage but hey is
pretty good all right so so far we can
create a website I mean not the best
looking but hey it's a website so why do
you care so now let's move on to the CSS
so the thing I've been bragging about
all along and you'll see why I've been
bragging about so we could apply CSS
directly to this file but I want to keep
just like a separate notes for you guys
so go ahead and close this folder in
your text editor and go in and close out
of your text editor and then going to
now you can keep your browser open but
this one close the tab because that live
service off and then everything I talk
about is fountain can be found at w3
schools thing so let's just go back to
our folder structure and and then we're
gonna move on to basically where you
store that project which was right on my
desktop HTML sandbox and let's move now
it's been create a new folder so outside
of HTML sandbox so we're in here when do
needle and then folder run call this CSS
underscore sandbox and then here just
going to open this with your code editor
so create a new file so now we're going
to start with our HTML because you need
an index on an HTML file to um you know
what's a call like link your CSS to
because you cannot create a website
without the index.html file so now let's
create a style dot CSS file but before
you do that create a new folder for your
CSS stay organized
one word stay organized inside of that
folder you can gonna create your style
of CSS all right so now so now let's
move back to the nefesh ml we can use
that shortcut i've taught you and then
what's gonna name is our CSS sandbox
now we're gonna medially go press open
open with live server now this will open
not if you in your default browser but I
will going to open up on here so now
inside of here I want to create a header
and that was pretty div and we'll give
it a class of header by the way you can
give this also a class of main header or
an ID also of main header so I can have
like multiple so instead like header
main so we can have like multiple
classes and ID's between and I won't
code in one more class let's just say
not just only main header you can say
like title you can do that too that'll
be two classes is that one so inside
this header I want to create an h1 that
says my web site alright so once again
very ugly looking download resets the
size so it'll be easier now we gave this
thing a class of header but before we do
that you can actually target these
elements B so let me teach you one way
of doing CSS and that is with the style
of attribute so adding a style now let's
just say I want to make
is the color of its own font color so
they'll be color red if I save CSS
applied alright very lucky now we could
even do let's just say font size and
make that 20 pixels there but that's not
big different hundred pixels there
actually be a lot better to read all
right but that looks very ugly so now
you can do all that
the second way of applying CSS is so
basically our main goal is to keep your
CSS separate from your HTML so if I were
to create a style tag in there twice now
learn this new syntax so what should say
on target this header so just the
element header so I would use header
curly brace braces and enter so we can
get this nice format inside of here you
can have multiple CSS Styles per
attribute so you will see I targeted the
element header here but if I want to
target the class of header I put a dot
for class let's just I want to target
the idea of header which it doesn't
exist right now but you could add it
hash tag for ID
alright so real easy right now we're
just targeting regular header and then
we want the color of it to be green
alright doesn't look really good by red
so get the point now the third way to
supply CSS which is the most recommended
is your external but how do we link this
file inside of here because if I were to
go ahead and do header and if I did
color to be red nothing's done like
nothing's happening here and that is
because we haven't linked it so if I do
a link tag now I can say start I can now
get to go to this folder so the C is
inside the CSS folder so if I were to do
CSS style of CSS if I press save we have
a color
all right so that's now being learned
about one attribute which is color now
how am I gonna get rid of this now the
first thing I want to do is get rid of
something I want to get rid of this
default margin that a house and padding
whatever it has so to get rid of
something default so like basically the
roots are like the root of your root is
a fasters curly braces and not even sent
margin : zero so no more margin so now
is gonna get rid of padding which I'll
explain later
so now explain padding quickly it's
gonna create a div with the ID so let's
use ideals practice already skills and
call a box and more specifically box one
so now box one it doesn't display yet
because we had to create box one because
is it empty so there's an attribute of
sounds gonna do a background color
attribute which will make it red
now still doesn't display because there
is nothing in here so if I was to put an
age let's just I was to put hello it
would display with the background of red
but that's not very helpful now I'm
trying to display how padding works so
I'm inside I'm just gonna saying I can
put box basically all right so you see
this element so it has box right now
this back has a background color of red
so with margin if I was use margin watch
what happens so I can do margin top and
let's do 10 pixels we move from the top
so this thing moved away from the top if
I were to do 30 pixels it really went
further away from the top if I was to do
margin bottom with you and I see let's
do margin left this thing move left away
but let's just say I want to keep this
red color consistent right like I did
not want to move the red close by when
you move the element inside so I can do
padding top it'll be closest to 10
pixels
we had this color I'm gonna be
padding-bottom that is we had that color
too
I'm gonna do padding left ten pixels we
got that - I can do padding right which
you won't see at a moment but ten pixels
now you can see that all this it's the
same ten pixels so there's an easier way
to write this so you could have done
padding basically and instead 10 pixels
10 pixels 10 pixels for all four but
being it was shortened to see one more
10 pixels and then if I were to comment
it so basic comment this is the same
shortcuts of control and a forward slash
but this is how comments look like
so there's app for slash asterisk
asterisk for slash so if I were to
comment that out it's the same to prove
it to those of you who don't believe
comments do anything get rid of the same
patent so I can do 20 pixels same thing
so this is pretty consistent so that was
padding and margin so I can get rid of
that now I want to create a nice-looking
header so if I can go now the font let
me talk mention about font this font is
very ugly
Times New Roman I do not like it I'll be
surprised if you like it
so let's target our body all right this
this is like the main so I want the font
of the whole entire web page should be
the same if I can do body and let's do
font family now by default visual studio
code gives you all these options
Alfonse and now let's gonna choose
sans-serif this is much better in my in
my vision oh so this looks a lot better
now let's gonna give this a background
color oh let's just give it so now it's
not all about colors so let's not like
that by the way yeah sorry
so to give this my website a background
color about we just learned something
you can get body go back on coloring the
whole webpage will be that color so if I
was to get rid of that and let's target
our header but more specifically on
targeted class
so we've learned so I want here's one
rule use classes and ID's more than the
actual element will make your life a lot
easier so dot header so inside of this
header we'll go ahead and say well I
want souls to save to get rid of that
let's do a background color of hash tag
see you cc or three three three sorry
all right now you can get all these hex
these are called hex hex colors so we're
gonna do a hex color and then like pick
your own color so Google has a pretty
good format for choosing so colors so
like this is your hexadecimal value that
you would use alright so let's move back
to our web page and then now here's one
thing you realize that you're realizing
there's not much space the font isn't
the right color everything so if you
recall from the first example you can
change the color of elements
it's a font color white I'm still this
looks kind of ugly so let's do padding
because we want the background color to
extend it listed 10 pixels padding so
all around not too bad those do 20
pixels even better so this looks a lot
better than this this is a lot now lets
them do something more better so red
looks a lot vibrant now let's add some
content to play around with so let's so
I want to style a list or more
specifically let's top buttons so
something that's very exciting to style
will be a button and let's go say button
now the first thing we do not want
inside the header we want to criticize
ssin
there and then if we can fix this by
shift-tab
now first thing you'll realize when I'm
zoomed in only a hundred percent so
normal the button is really small has no
margin so we might want to use margin on
the button
so let's gonna target a button because
buttons are like general so you don't
specifically want like you'll want a
button to be like the same everywhere
like you want to want your one area have
a button that's like nine huge and
another one be small you want them like
all similar so for this button this give
us some margin Barwon and i want to give
this a margin top of 10 pixels all right
margin left 10 pixels now to increase
select the size of this button you have
two ways you can use height and the
width property so we can do height of
this to be like 20 pixels and then the
width to be 20 pixels but as really
small so let's do 200 pixels and then
just to be hundred but that's pretty big
still it's a fixing pistol all right
this is pretty okay let's do 25 and then
just to be 75 I can see I can play
around with this button all day but we
have a better way to do this I mean just
do padding basically and then for a top
and bottom so on so let's see let me
show you yeah so let's do top and bottom
padding to be let's do 30 pixels top and
bottom padding and then 40 pixels left
and right all right that's kind of big
exactly so you don't split these in half
since they're not what you think they'll
be it's still big but you're
accumulating music all right this is a
good side buddy now if I were to zoom in
this button has a weird border so we can
get rid of that border or going to
create a new border so because a border
property and unless it say none no
border all right we got rid that border
yay now let's go ahead and do a good
nice background color I did not like the
background go let's do the hashtag
see see all right let's do three two
three and let's give it a color
attribute a white so the text inside is
white and then looks a lot better than
used to but in a hundred percent
actually looks a lot better
let's give it a radius border radius
like make us circular so we can do
border radius and then it's dependent on
pixels so let's do five pixels border
radius and you can already see this
buttons kind of rounded looks a lot
better
let's do ten pixels we need to even do
30 pixels now looking the better we can
even do 50 pixels now you can do
percentages so I'm going to look 50
percent which will make it like a weird
circle you can do a hundred percent
which is the same but you can actually
do 25 percent yeah is like your weird
stuff I think 25 pixels looks pretty
good but five pixels looks better if you
like a box button where I go along and I
wrong
all right so our border radius is 5
pixels so this looks pretty nice but
here's one thing might be realizing
there is no like cursor place like if
you were to click on like you don't
necessarily need a cursor click since
most of Chrome doesn't do it but like if
you were on a website and you want to
click on something your cursor turns
like that well that's why you get a
property of pointer no cursor and then
we can say pointer so I want to cursor
be pointer when you on it so whenever on
this button little cursor yeah now so
you will see that most buttons like
anything that you almost hover on hover
is the new ones like when you put your
mouse over as a different color or like
a different style to it so to access
this in your styling we do button :
hover so almost anything can have a
hover State so with this let's change
the background color to be transparent
so but then we lose the text so we want
to change it to black all right still
good but that doesn't look very
beautiful now let's add a border of
let's do late one pixel border so we
want to solve it and then we want it
black all right those do that all right
now bad but you'll see it's kind of
moving and to show you that is actually
moving do a paragraph or lorem 10 let me
share all right look watch what happens
to the paragraph the paragraph moves and
that is because there's no border
defined previously so it adds an extra
one pixel to it which moves everything
by one pixel so for that reason you can
have a one pick so you want to have a
one pixel border that just solid as well
and transparent so no color and then now
it looks a lot better now this is also
very fast-moving so you can have a
transition property
now don't worry if you do not understand
everything all this can be found in the
w3 schools so now what trap is it
smoothly feeds in so it kind of had that
animation - so basically get this done
and animation amazing so you have that
as well which I mean looks amazing I
like stir this all day so we have to
style the button now you guys you get
like the basic purpose of CSS so far now
we can actually so I want to go in and
style form so forms are very ugly by
default and you can see this text like
she looks pretty good if I show you the
section actually looks pretty good so
let's go to style form so form so once
again we have that action which we don't
need now the label for first name so
let's recreate that form we were trying
to create before and this time we're not
have no line breaks no none that so
input text and then look how it
placeholder - will sing into her first
name and then was to label yarn so for
last name last name and it'll be like
input type text and then we live like an
art placeholder for entire last name and
then have another label for email and it
will mean looks an email address and
then let's do input type of email and
then have a place holder of enter email
address let's gonna all right so I did
not apply any styling on this and let's
have an input for submit and put submit
with the value of submit and then let's
give it a class so now let me go to move
back so looks like I say classes are
general what if we give this a class
with dot so we make this element styling
into a dart so a class based
just for class so this button change
back but what if we give this to class a
button and you will see our submit
button gets default because the default
thing now it's gonna make our button so
we want to make a display so we want it
to be a block line element all right
so block so this is on its own line
automatically right now it's gonna play
with our form that with you earlier
create we just created so we do form and
let's start so now I want to give us a
margin all round of 10 pixels so this is
moved around but I want a margin top to
be even more so let's make a 20 pixel
margin top all right now let's do
nothing else here let's move on to our
inputs so you're gonna like nest
elements just like an HTML your nesting
elements here now this is an input we do
not want to play with this so if we can
do bracket and we just give it a type so
I wanted to type to be only the inputs
our text and then we can do a comma for
another one and we'll stay input that
and we'll say type equals for email
because and then now we can do curly
braces so we can actually target to
three elements all at the same time for
the same silent just because of that
alright so before we move on to this
let's target our labels and make them a
display a block and then let's make them
have an all around margin of ten pixels
but only on the top and bottom not on
the left or right all right let's give
this five pixels instead all right so
let's give these forms inside a padding
of all around of so on not all right so
on top and bottom
I want 20 pixels and I'm left and right
let's just do yes I could so 20 pizzas
tops in bottom but nothing on the left
or right all right that looks pretty
ugly ten I think eight will look amazing
there's seven there got seven looks a
lot better all right don't worry we'll
get a margin too
so we'll get the marginal ten pixels and
then zero left to right all right
let's actually give this a margin three
pixels luckily that was a lot better so
now let's give it a width so there's a
new attribute so we talked about this
for width let's give it a 100% width so
the whole entire page basically now this
looks okay so we actually just created a
really good form so test yeah I know
whatever now let's give it a border
radius so let's make a look even better
let's give it a border radius of five
pixels now you will see this ugly stuff
so we just got a very ugly looking form
but I can actually do border and let's
fix that so we do one pixel border which
is gonna be solid it'll make it hashtag
CCC all right so pretty good so far but
let's give it margin so let's give it
padding on the left or right of one
pixel alright so that looks a lot better
it's a little sulfur here's our form so
this looks a lot better so we did like
nano and they're productions and then
like nano productions add in gmail.com
plate what is our email address yeah
I'll figure that out but yeah so
basically we just dialed our form so
this may look a lot better broad kind of
zoom in like if you were to zoom out a
bit so this looks a lot better trust me
like this looks a whole lot better than
the previous form if you have seen
alright so this is most we talked about
a lot of attributes so far now let's go
ahead
now table styling lovely can actually
create a quick table alright so I do not
want to waste much time though so table
inside this table let's just go ahead
and do a tea head
Deonte age only like first name day
something like last name and then tea
body well I like tea or teeny well like
love it
um and then anything will be Smith then
he another table row you know like TD
will be like John and then another TD
would be like role whatever alright so
we have this form now first of all the
font looks a lot better so this looks
pretty good I don't know what to say but
alright so with the table let's make
this a width of a hundred percentage
like alright there we go we got a lot
more spacing I'll give this a border or
one pixel solid and let's do like
hashtag thing to do alright pretty good
but I want to give us some margin so
let's give it actually let me teach you
something real cool so if I were to do
margin of nine to five same width of
ninety percent and if we did margin Auto
it's already Center so basically we have
centered this and one way or the other
and then let's target our tables T arms
let's see if they can get a border of
one pixel solid I should get moving
alright so we can do no TDs and th there
we go so we just got a border for our
elements but we can actually fix this
issue by just giving them a background
color background color
Alysha st. hash so I have four or four
and four all right there we go
this looks a lot better table and yeah
we just got in really handy table or
let's just have now we can actually play
around so if we look back our
is th so we did t-table th elements you
can just say we want to board a bottom
on them a 1 pixel solid and I should I
see anything right 3 3 3 exactly so that
look hashtag for anything so this will
look pretty good too still not bad if I
do see some myself at all very nice with
me so let's move so this is basically
not everything else ESS obviously if I
was to check w3schools there is like a
bucket load of more stuff to cover trust
me but this is enough to get you started
on like like you can just read this for
a bit and then like the archer boots we
have talked about can actually help you
with everything else so I we have
basically just like created like a short
cheat sheet of like the basic like
introduction to these new attributes
that you have never ever heard about but
this is amazing so far now in this view
we will not cover of creating a website
so of all day but check out a video
sooner on my channel which we will learn
on which you can create we will like
create a website using everything that
we have learned alright so check out
Nano productions for that type of video
and then we'll I'll see you
[Music]